There you go.
>> What's up, guys? How you all doing?
>> It's uh I'm going. We are um
in for a hold the disk live on Discord.
Ooh, maybe we should do it on Discord at
some point. I would be
>> you can stream it to Discord uh if you
wanted to.
>> If group site works on Discord, we'll
set that up. Uh I got a special guest
today you can say hi to a pop-in
experience.
>> Oh, hey guys.
>> We got Aaron over here.
>> What's up, dude?
>> All right, today we have some So,
welcome to the AI that work show. Uh we
have very special special guest today in
addition to Aaron, we got Kevin Gregory.
Um and this is a program where uh what
we do is we tell you how to take real AI
engineering concepts that have been
working in production in the field and
apply them to your own projects to build
AI that is good enough to ship to
production customers. And By Bob, you
want to give an intro to what we're
talking about today?
>> Yes, but before we do that, let's give
quick background of uh who the heck we
are, Dex.
>> Okay, fine.
>> So, I'm By Bob.
>> We're still working on the intro.
>> Yeah, we we um as you can tell, this is
not our official job. We write code most
of the time.
Uh my name is By Bob. I work on BAML, uh
which is a programming language. Dex.
>> Uh I'm Dex. I work uh on Human Layer,
where we're uh helping people use AI to
solve hard problems in brownfield
complex code bases.
>> And Kevin, give a little bit about
yourself as well.
>> Sure. So, I work at Evolution IQ. I'm an
ML engineer. At Evolution IQ, we build
claims guidance systems for disability
and personal insurance carriers.
>> So, you've got you've got solid AI in
AI that works live happening in your
company, is what I'm hearing.
Um but
>> That's right.
>> So, today's episode, as many of you
know, was um scheduled around dynamic
UIs. So, we did do a little bit of work
on dynamic UIs. And before we get to the
really, really exciting part that I that
has
exciting enough that has caused us to
derail the topic today into something
even better.
Uh and which is why Kevin is on, so you
should really, really get excited for
that. We're going to show you
a snippet of dynamic UIs. Why is my
audio bad?
>> Yeah. This is uh we had a we had a
breaking news event. Um
essentially, while you're pulling that
up, I will just kind of tell story a
little bit, which is um
we did an episode, actually the very
first episode of AI that works, um
was about how to do large-scale qual-
classification and how to build kind of
um
not necessarily the evals themselves,
but how to build your pipelines around
being capable of leveraging incremental
and kind of like very almost like unit
testy style evals, so that you can build
these complex pipelines while being able
to understand like how things work and
where stuff went wrong. Um so, I'm going
to share really quickly just a couple of
those, and then I'll hand it back to
Vibhav to show you what we will be
talking about in a very soon upcoming
episode.
But, um this is the episode from March
uh 31st. We talked about the simple way
to do classification, how to pass a
schema in, how to add probes to be able
to understand and like narrow down your
categories with embedding or naive rag
or using an LLM. Um and so, we we did
this uh exercise, and uh we wrote some
code for it, but it was as most of the
time we kind of just riffing and doing
the concepts. What Kevin has done is
actually taken all these concepts and
built a actual production-grade system
with evals and testing and all kinds of
fancy stuff. So, we're going to dive
deep on kind of his journey in building
that, and then also in um
in kind of the code itself and and what
it looks like and kind of what worked
and what didn't. And uh I'm really
excited to learn. I actually
intentionally didn't want to know too
much about this, so I'm sure I'll have
loads and loads of questions and we'll
have eyes on the chat, so please drop
your questions in the chat as well.
>> You can kind of view it like um
uh you can kind of view it as almost
like a level three of the concepts that
we normally have done and it is just
insane what Kevin has managed to do.
But I will give you a sneak preview of
what
of what um
we meant when we meant dynamic UIs.
So I'm going to
>> thought real quick I
I just got a comment that Five O's
volume is a little low so I'm going to
turn down my dynamic volume and so
hopefully now you can turn it up and
you'll get a more balanced mix.
>> how do you do that actually? I'm need a
Riverside. How do I set up my dynamic
volume?
>> Uh if you go click the settings in the
top right you can there's like an output
volume.
>> Um I don't see my
>> slider.
>> Um
is it in settings? I I mean oh all
settings.
Output volume. Mine is
maxed out all the way.
>> maxed out I will cap mine a little bit
so that people can turn it up a little
bit and they hear us at the same volume.
>> Okay. Well, uh hopefully this audio is
better. Uh if there are any more issues,
please let us know in the chat.
So, what is dynamic UIs? Well, I think
the idea of dynamic UIs is you should be
able to build any sort of content. So
like in this case
I have a
fun little image of like Dexter and I's
thing over here or like uh let me see if
I can get a different one.
Uh one. So like over here we did cloud
code for non-voting task. Yeah, that
works number 20.
It'd be really nice if I could build a
UI for this element automatically. So
here's the two steps that I do under the
hood.
I ask you ask an LLM to take the same
code and describe code back to me
in a way that actually Yeah, sorry.
>> Yeah, you need to generate a new schema.
>> Sorry, yes.
Uh I pressed the wrong button.
>> any socks or dogs in that image.
>> Um where are we at?
So if I take this one I go to this, what
I can do is I can actually ask an LLM to
go and describe the schema that
describes this model.
Once I have a schema that describes this
model
I can do a bunch of things and I'll just
quickly describe what the schema is
really fast and we can just burn through
it really fast.
Which is we have an episode which has
title, substring, series info, all this
other information. Series info, stream
details, schedule, um
and a bunch of other metadata over here.
And then the return type is just an
episode.
Well, after that I can run this code
individually and what should happen in
theory is given this image and given
that schema,
I should be able to pull out really nice
structured objects coming out of this.
And you're seeing that I'm doing very
dynamic stuff over here where I'm
actually rendering I could render this
whole thing as JSON, I could render as
YAML, I could render it in like pretty
format in some ways if that you consider
this pretty.
Um I can the last thing that will be
showing soon is how to actually also
build a React component that renders
this. But if any of you have built
dynamic React components before,
it's actually quite simple as long as
you show the React component this is my
shape of my object.
Now just turn this into React component
and I'm going to give you something of
that JSON shape, it will know how to go
do that.
>> Amazing.
>> is kind of dynamic schema stuff we'll
walk through. We'll walk through this
code in much more detail and talk about
how to go do this.
Uh this code is open source so we'll
send this out. Uh uh
>> Nice. Has mustache true.
>> Say again? Has mustache. Um I do not
have a mustache and it is not nearly as
glorious as this man's. But I do have
the glasses.
>> Anyways, that's a preview of what's
coming soon.
>> Yeah. And this is what we mean by
dynamic UIs. But today's episode is I
think infinitely more fun than anything
I have to talk about.
Um and then um
there's a really fun question is like um
do LLMs know YAML? The answer is yes.
Uh they're quite familiar with it at
this point.
Um
but
Kevin, why don't we take it away? Why
don't we do a little primer on the
classification video like Dexter was
walking us through it. Uh Kevin can
guide us through a little bit of it in
the beginning and then I want to talk
about kind of the thought processes that
you walked through, and I know you have
some stuff to show us.
>> Mhm.
>> But, let's describe the problem, and
then perhaps show the final result, and
then work backwards to how we got there.
>> Yeah, that sounds good. So, let me go
ahead and share my screen, and I can go
through We can do some Scala trough to
just help describe the problem.
So, the problem is, you know, as as
Datsun by Bob said,
is uh large-scale classification. So,
what that means is
every take if we have, say,
a lot of
uh um
a problem where we have a lot of
classes, you know, in the case that I
was looking at, we had, and I'll
describe kind of in detail in a little
bit,
um what is these categories are. We have
over 1,400 categories. And we get from
these 1,400 categories, we have a user
query.
So, let's just call that
query. Then, so we have a user query,
and it goes into these categories, and
our system has to select ultimately the
best category, right?
So,
from 1,400 to one, and we'll just call
this one
Let's see.
Call this selected
final category.
>> And to be to like make this a little
more real, this was like a hardware
store like thing, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah, exactly. So, the example
that I looked at, it was we had um
I can show actually
>> Yeah, you want to show some of the
categories?
>> Yeah, why don't we just walk through it?
I think it's Looking at the data is
always the most clear.
1,400 Oh my god, Andrew.
>> Yeah. So, we had
>> You want to zoom in?
>> Zoom in? Sure.
>> Perfect.
>> Yeah.
>> That's good. All right. So, these are
the categories, right? It's It basically
categories that you would see at a
hardware store. So, if you go to like
lowes.com or homedepot.com, you'll
probably see appliances, refrigerators,
and then in there there's like French
door refrigerators, right? And so you'll
see these are the categories that you
would see in an appliance store. And you
can imagine this would generalize to,
you know, like Amazon or any sort of
retail. And a lot of other
examples as well, but specifically here
we had 1,400 categories.
Right? And so how do we go from a user
query of like,
you know, ceiling fan,
and how do we figure out which is the
best category to do that?
And,
you know, there are a bunch of different
ways that you can do this. The most kind
of naive way is you just take all 1,400
categories, you dump everything into you
can just dump everything into an LLM and
say give me the best category.
Um you can also just do straight
embeddings where you just,
you know, pick the most similar uh
the most similar outcome to the
category.
But the problem with doing both of those
is
you really, when you're doing that, you
really only have a couple of levers that
you can pull.
So when you're
just using an LLM, you you only have
really the prompt and then the LLM that
you're using. And there are a couple of
keyword arguments you can use, but in
general you don't have
that many
If if your system isn't performing well,
there's not a lot you can do to change
it.
Um with embeddings, really, you know,
it's similar. You can change the
embedding model that you're using, but
there isn't too many
there aren't too many knobs you can
turn.
So the question
that they put that Vimov and Dex pose in
the first video is how do we create a
system with more probes, more
breakpoints where you can kind of see
the inputs and outputs and things that
you can change?
And so what I did
is
>> the naive version down here is like the
basically like here's here's 1,400
calorie categories, excuse me, and like
LLM pick which one this this query is
related to, right?
>> So what I did is, let's see. Do you
think it'd be better, Dex, to just
create a new one or kind of break this
one apart? I think it might be best to
break this one apart.
>> Yeah, go for it.
>> Yeah, so
So, what I ended up doing was, okay, so
what if we take these 1,400 categories
and and we use an embedder
and instead of having it give us the
best one, we have it give us the top,
say, 100. We have it give us the top 100
categories, right?
And, let's see. This is Let's see. This
is a vector store. And then,
we could dump all 100 of these
categories into
uh
an LLM and say, you know, pick a final
category.
But, I took it one step further and I
said, okay, so now that we have these
100 categories, we can get an even
smaller set, we'll call it 50.
Where is the text? Here we go.
So, 50 categories.
And this one is getting narrowed with an
LLM. So, we take the output from the
embedder and we say, hey,
hey, LLM, like, here's the query, here's
100 categories, give me the best 50.
And then, what we do is
we take those 50 and then we put those
into the final LLM and say, now's the
final category. Select the final
category of these top 50, right?
And
the great thing about this, I'm getting
rid of this now, is there's a lot of
breakpoints or probes as they were
described them in the first video,
right? There's
That's fine.
So, we can see, right, if we have the
correct answer somewhere, we can see if
the correct answer drops out in this
first 100, in this second 50, or in this
kind of final answer.
And we can control the different inputs
and outputs into these.
So, for instance, the
>> When you say inputs and outputs, I I I
think I think like one thing that's like
kind of worth noting is like so the
signature of narrow with embeddings,
right? Is like query
uh and then you basically just get out a
list of categories, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Um or I guess it's like a a big list of
categories.
>> To a smaller list of categories.
>> To a smaller list of categories, right?
But there's also like hyperparameters
here, like, you know, number of number
of like number of number of output
categories, right? This is kind of like
your you have your like top K and all
these things that have like nothing to
do with the query or the like content
that the LLM is working with, but they
kind of control the like the
implementation, the like dimensions of
your system.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And there's also something that's
kind of even more fun to do is you can
think about this narrow with LLM, right?
This kind of second narrowing.
The the signature would be you'd have
the query.
You'd have the array of categories. So
it
you would think that it's almost the
exact signature as the narrow with
embeddings.
But
one of the things that you can play with
is there's no guarantee or there's not
guarantee, there's no
reason that the categories coming out of
here necessarily have to be the
categories that go into these 50
categories. You can have an intermediate
step if you want.
And that basically says, "Hey, beef up
these categories. Turn them from what we
saw here of you know, just heating,
venting, and cooling, heaters, wall
heaters, and create a whole sentence
around them or a paragraph or make them
much more descriptive." Right? So you
can
by introducing these new breakpoints,
there's a lot of knobs you can turn
beyond just
50 categories, 25 categories, or what
have you.
>> I'm going to pause cuz I think there's a
really good question. Akash asked a
question, "Isn't this costly because
you're just spending a lot of question
you're spending a lot of input tokens
and output tokens?" But uh I think uh
what we're really focusing on here,
Akash, is actually accuracy. There's
some workflows, like for example, if
you're a medical billing company and you
need to bill ICDC codes. So, ICDC codes
are these insurance codes that you use
that have examples such as, "This
patient had a laceration on the right
pinky toe." It's super specific, and
that's how they bill for insurance. And
>> And there's separate codes for each toe,
right? Basically.
>> Literally, yes. Literally, yes. If you
There's like 80,000 codes or something.
And if you're an insurance provider, you
need to If that code is wrong, you don't
pay out. So, the hospital doesn't get
paid.
So, in some cases, like their entire
jobs, whose job it is to take these
categories and like go
go fill them out.
So, the important thing here isn't
actually to consider cost. It's like
First, we can worry about getting it
performant with 100% accuracy or solving
for every solution that we have, and
then we can worry about reducing
uh cost. And it's similar with latency.
There are ways to reduce latency. There
are ways to make this fast. We can talk
about that stuff in a bit. But, I think
>> We talked about that a lot on the voice
agent one, right?
>> Yeah, we did talk about that a little
bit.
>> you How do you use a smart model to
supervise the dumb model so the dumb
model can move fast? But, yeah, no, I
think I think what you're saying is
exactly right. Like, there's this
spectrum. We talked about this a lot.
There's this spectrum between like cheap
and accurate. And what we've said in the
past is like, "Cool, if you want to see
if AI can solve a problem at all,
use the expensive, like cheap in terms
of engineering time. Just throw 03 or
GPT-5 max thinking at it and see see if
AI can even solve it in the first place.
And then, once cost and latency becomes
an issue, then you can engineer it down
and be like, 'Okay, let's make the
prompt really good for all the use cases
that we know need to work.'"
>> Or we can take this whole pipeline and
like get the final input-output pairs
and train a fine-tuned model end-to-end
that's super tiny, runs on the fly.
Like, all that stuff becomes possible,
but only if you have it working in the
first place.
But, there's something about Kevin's
work that really inspired me. Cuz like,
if you go back, like this is actually
more advanced than what we did in our
video, a little bit more.
Uh cuz he added that extra step in there
that we didn't think about doing.
But, what Kevin really shocked me on is
actually the UI that he came up with of
how to evaluate these results. Cuz it's
not actually sufficient to write this
code. The real part
>> Hell yeah, I haven't I actually haven't
seen this yet. I'm super stoked to see
this.
>> Okay.
The real part about these systems is how
do you actually think through these
systems? Um
>> Mhm.
>> So, let's go let's go Why don't we take
a look at the final UI that we came up
with and why don't we see the UI
Let's start with the final cuz I think
it's always the best and then we'll show
how we got there.
>> Okay. We'll show the end and then yeah,
forest from the trees first.
>> Exactly. And then remember, for everyone
who listens to this problem, then first
thing to remember is just like
the problem is we have a query that
comes in and we have a hardware store
that we want to pick the right category
based on the query the user put
>> Yeah. And I think to to, you know, the
the point that they were saying, right?
Like at building this pipeline
that and with Cursor and Claude code and
even Cur- Cursor's new CLI that they
just shipped, right? Like, this is
pretty easy to build something like this
now, right? This
is almost free. Like, anyone here on the
call could probably build this within a
week or two, right? So, like, building
this pipeline is not hard. What's hard
is
figuring out
um how to ingest the information in a
way that's helpful and tells you what to
do to make the pipeline really, really
good.
That's kind of where the magic comes in.
And so, here's the UI. So, this is a
couple of different tabs, but right off
the bat, I I came up with 68 test cases
from uh some LLM generated, I reached
out to some family members to see what
they would look for.
And right off the bat, um I mean, you
can see that
overall, it's doing really well,
so 14 it got wrong, 54 it got correct,
right?
But, what's I think even more exciting
is when you scroll down here, you can
see
where in those different stages the
correct you know the correct answer fell
at.
And so it looks like I mean embedding
filtering isn't on here because it made
it through the embedding filter every
single time.
The LLM filtering
>> And that's interesting. You took it out
of the UI because it literally didn't
matter. You're like it this just isn't a
problem. So it's the embeddings are
correct enough.
>> it's still in the UI. It's just it's not
showing up because it's not here.
>> Okay, got it.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. It's just it's it's it's
looking for the different types of
errors and it's just graphing them.
Yeah. Um
But what's interesting is you can see
here like okay, so
two of the 14 times the that that LLM
filtering stage was where the mistake
was. But the last you know the other 12
times it was that final selection was
where the mistake was.
And I mean there are a couple of things
that you can do here. To me the most
obvious thing to do is to
make the LLM filter more restrictive and
see if that final LLM selector performs
better with fewer categories.
And so you can see over here I'm not
sure how
>> I did. Yeah, so this is just version
zero, right? With 100 embedding
candidates and 50 LLM candidates.
And when you look at version one
the accuracy gets even better, right?
We're now at
uh 13 failures versus I mean 14. But
you can see that yeah the LLM filtered
out more and the final selection
um
it's is is still the main issue, but
it's not making as many mistakes as it
was before.
And this was with LLM candidates 25. I
mean you can even kind of look even
further at this, right? If you look at
15, performance went down a little bit.
So maybe something closer to 25 is just
you know it's kind of the right thing.
>> But Okay, so you're you're tuning the
knobs of the I mean I don't want to use
the word hyper parameters cuz that's a
very specific thing, but you're turning
the knobs of the pipeline
by building very visual easy to evaluate
representations of how different
combinations of parameters perform.
>> Exactly. And that's kind of the what's
interesting is right out of the gate is
you can see like
where's the where's the wrong answer
happening? Like what's the mistake in
the pipeline? Where are the faults? And
it's because we've added in all these
different break points and created a UI
that makes that just kind of jump out at
you. All right, so what we're doing is
>> jump in real fast.
>> Yeah.
>> You keep saying the right answer. Was
the right answer manually classified?
>> Yeah, so the right answer was um
I don't know. It's it's funny you say
that, right? Yeah, so the right answer
was all all me and you know, my family
coming up with like what they would want
out of a search query.
You can you can argue whether or not
they're correct, right? Like if if you
know, I don't know hardware that way or
or that well.
I mean you can argue and say like, well
um maybe I don't maybe
when I put something in like the actual
right answer to what I'm putting in is
something different than I'm expecting,
but I think that's kind of
more of a philosophical question about
like what does right mean in this case?
And I guess that's something that like
the PMs would decide, right?
>> Well,
but yeah, like people that care about
the product could be engineers.
But yeah, but maybe the PM.
>> So
So what's what's interesting one of the
interesting things is um I mean if I
don't know if I was looking at this
yesterday, I think. And you can go over
here to the test case analysis.
And you can look at let's look at one
that I got wrong. Let's stove with red
knobs.
Uh where was that? That was one we were
looking at and I just I just passed it.
>> Just pull any of them. It's fine.
>> Here we go.
So
and you can see so you can see what it's
doing, right?
These are all the ones that made it this
probably too small. Let's zoom in some.
>> Yeah, that's perfect.
>> You can see all everything that made it
to the embedding filter and you can see
the ones that made it to the LLM filter
and you can see what it finally
selected, right? It selected appliance
appliances ranges gas ranges.
>> Oh, this is cool as heck.
>> The quote-unquote correct answer was
double oven gas ranges and this is
where, you know, and if I would actually
brought up the point and like, well,
this might actually be okay cuz it might
be okay to give a more general answer
rather than a more specific answer.
>> Can right?
I if you have more to show here, um I I
I like I would love to see we can come
back to this or you can keep going here.
I would love to take a peek at some of
the prompts that you're using at each of
these stages or like how the how like
how you're embedding the query. Okay.
>> Yeah, um but I think Kevin's point here
is about the general specific was really
interesting. We actually got into really
interesting like 20-minute side track on
this uh or 10-minute side track on this
is really fascinating cuz like
what is right or wrong
is actually really subjective in a lot
of use cases. So like in this scenario
for example,
imagine I've gone to Amazon and it
actually picked double oven gas In this
case the answer is double oven gas range
but imagine picked that and the answer
the ground truth was like gas ranges.
Based on the UI that I had, it might be
so easy to go to gas ranges for the user
that it might actually be okay to be
more specific.
On the other hand,
the LLM you might argue that I want
actually want to take the user to a more
general page rather than a specific page
for some other reason because of the UI
of how my product works the UX of it
works. Because maybe if I go to gas
ranges, I have a section that shows gas
ranges double oven gas range at the top
then um shows uh electric gas ranges and
everything else right below
and it allows me to go see that very
easily.
But I think the important part here is
like what's good or bad is really
subjective based on your use case and
even the degree of correctness that you
have for an answer in your ground truth
set, you should ask yourself like how
bad is this?
Cuz technically this is a failure for
our eval set,
but I might argue that this is actually
correct.
Um and I might want to reword what it
means to be a failure be like, if I got
in the right subtree and I'm too
specific, that's okay.
If I'm in the right subtree and I'm
general by one level, that's okay. We
can change the definition of scoring.
>> Because you can put in your you like
like like the whole point is like you
work backwards from what's a good user
experience and you can put into your UI
like the breadcrumbs of like, okay,
here's the narrowest category, here's
the parent category, here's and you can
let the user just navigate up
themselves. And so it's like what's the
risk of getting it wrong and how
important is it to get the final
category right versus like the 50
categories right?
>> Exactly. And then like Charles brought
up a really interesting point, which is
in this kind of situation, you can ask
LLM to disambiguate with the confidence
as well. That's another way to build
your UI where you can actually ask to
disambiguate it's like if it's
ambiguous, go ask uh for follow-up
questions. But you can also build it
directly into your UI so you not add an
iteration where you just take the user
to the right page and you make it easy
for them to opt-in to the right
direction.
Cuz it's unlikely that they're if
they're looking for a stove, they want
to end up in like
showers or like uh buying like a rain
shower. It that that seems very, very
unlikely or they want to buy like a
hammer or something or a safety eyewear.
Uh which I know some of the categories
in there. So as long as we're really,
really close and our UX makes it trivial
to translate,
we can get that's okay. The mistake is
forgiven almost in your product.
>> Yeah, it's I think it's like a question
of as a user, am I going to be upset if
I type in stove with red knobs and I get
gas ranges?
No, like not at all. Cuz odds are
there's going to be an icon for double
oven gas ranges right there and I might
see the stove with the red knobs in the
picture and it's like that's a perfectly
acceptable user experience.
And actually I have a a drop down over
here where we can change the correctness
definition. So if we
if we allow for more lenient, we can see
it it it gets it right. All right, the
table doesn't update cuz I I kind of
just put this together like just this
morning. But you can see it's right. And
then we go back to the error analysis,
we're at 84% correct.
And I didn't even do any additional
prompting kind of get it up. And this
this is very bare-bones prompting.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like you can basically it's
it's more about defining your problem in
a way that really understands your
language.
And I think like what's interesting here
is until you showed me this UI,
I really wasn't thinking about that
problem definition page. But when we
were looking at an aggregate, we could
actually go and be like, "Okay, let's
just look at a failure really quickly
and see what's wrong."
>> Yeah. Cuz initially you would think,
"Okay, well this is this has all the
information I need."
Right? I can see in each of those
breakpoints where the pipeline is
failing and where the mistakes are
happening.
So why do I need to look at it on a
case-by-case basis? And this is exactly
why. Cuz when you do that, what actually
happened is the pipeline and I disagreed
on whether or not we should be too
general or too specific. And it's like,
"Okay, that's really interesting that
we're having this disagreement because
either answer could be right just
depending on the UI, depending on the
product, depending on the user
experience that you want." And so that's
why it's so useful to be able to look at
it on a case-by-case basis. It made it
very easy to toggle between ones that
are correct and ones that are wrong,
right? Makes it very easy.
And what's interesting about what I
pointed out, kind of to the point we
were discussing earlier, I think as
engineers, like one of the things that
we like to do is we like to show that we
we're being good engineers, we care
about latency, right? And I I did this
where like I have the latency time here
to show how long each of these steps
takes.
But for what we're looking at now, what
we care about the prediction accuracy.
This
data does not change I I'm not going to
make any different decision with any
numbers that are here or whether or not
they're here or not. So, they shouldn't
be here at all, right? They're not
They're kind of just fun facts, but for
when we're making a decision using a UI
like this,
it's not useful at all. It's It's just
honestly it's just distracting.
Which I when until Vibhav pointed that
out, I thought that was a really good
point cuz we want to show that like,
"Hey, we're being good engineers. We're
paying attention to latency." But for
the use case of what this UI is trying
to do, it it doesn't add anything. It
just takes up space that distracts from
the actual point.
>> Um how easy is this to rerun? Like if
you change the prompts and can we get
like a V6 out of this and like see how
it performs?
>> We can. Yeah.
>> Okay. Cuz I'd be curious uh
>> It takes It takes some time, but
>> Okay. Okay.
>> can see, uh it's not It's not very fast,
but um I mean it it it depending on kind
of how many, you know, candidates we're
outputting. But if we want to run it and
then talk about something else, like we
certainly can.
>> One One of my favorite things to do with
Vibhav is uh roast my prompt uh because
he has incredible intuition about like
how LLMs like think and it like a
per token basis. I think it could be
really interesting to like look at the
prompts, um maybe make a tweak that we
think is going to make it better, and
then run it again, and then we can kind
of like zoom out and maybe like do a
couple questions and things like that.
Um but I'm Yeah, I'd be really curious
to kind of see see that done end to end
and just kind of like see this thing
working. Um so that people can pull this
down and mess with it.
>> Uh and we'll check the code into the AI
that works for you. Vibhav, you've been
working there, right, Kevin? Okay.
>> Um
>> We do this. Like we we can play with the
prompts a little bit, um and then we can
kick it off, and then I can show how we
got here cuz this is the end state.
There were some intermediate stages that
were
>> Yeah.
>> kind of funny almost.
Um
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. So, I mean we can do that uh
because I did very little very little
prompt engineering, right? Like no. I
just have bare-bones prompts. So, if we
look at the
pick the best category here, I pretty
much pulled this
straight from
the initial video that you all did. So,
there are two prompts that it's using.
Um there's pick the best categories,
which
seems pretty straightforward. And then
there's
pick the best category, right? This is
the LLM filtering, and then this is the
final LLM decision.
So,
>> You know what we should try? Um which
category is better? Pick the best cat
That the second one is failing more,
right?
>> Yes.
>> Why don't we just bump that up to GPT-5
um
if we can and just run that GPT-5 mini
or something instead of GPT-4o.
>> Okay.
Um I don't know if I have Let's see.
>> I thought that is not what I That is not
what I meant by prompt expertise.
>> Dude, this is uh this is the shortcut
that I've been learning, actually. You
don't actually need it there. You can
just change change it right there. You
can use the shorthand.
>> Okay.
>> So, just change that to GPT-5 and then
add GPT-5 mini. So, GPT-5 is good. Yeah,
and then instead of OpenAI, do
OpenAI-responses. Let's use the new
responses API cuz there are slight
differences.
>> All right, just like that?
>> Yeah. Um and
>> Do you want to test it real quick just
to make sure that works?
>> Can I just do that?
>> Yeah, do you have a test thing running
on that?
>> Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
>> If you don't have access I'll send you
an API key. Oh, it did not work. What
did it say?
>> Uh it looks like it was already running.
Maybe you interrupted it.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> No, it just died.
That's the right model?
>> Play. Can you run an LLM CLI test really
fast for me?
This in terminal. We just run it in
terminal real fast. And just run LLM CLI
test, yeah.
>> Just like that?
>> Yeah, that should work.
LLM CLI test. I'll just do
dash-dash-help. That's odd. Um live
stream fail, I guess. Um
>> You got an old version.
>> Oh.
>> You do UVX LLM CLI test.
>> Yeah. It's got to be
I
Yeah, just the UVX family CLI test.
There you go.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Uh I Yeah, and then just add in the dash
dash from.
Um
What dash dash from and then give it the
path to
>> source.
>> That's so it's CLI man.
>> Kyle says this experience is
>> so much. I was like, "Oh my god, what is
going on?" We actually now output the
version number for that reason. That's
it. That's perfect.
Uh Oh, and you don't have env var set
up.
>> Oh, you can't stream You can't stream
five without verifying your
organization. That's what it was.
>> Oh.
>> Let's just do GPT-4o then instead of 4o
mini.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
Okay, cool.
>> Kyle says this experience is making me
feel much better. Hey, we're all We're
all building and learning stuff
together.
>> we do code real time on the fly. I mean,
that is what we do over here. We're real
coding and make it work.
>> That worked. Cool.
>> Awesome.
>> Okay, so now
>> Let's go run this. Want to see if it got
better by just doing a small thing like
a model upgrade.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz if we can do a model upgrade and get
it better, then that I think the thing
that a lot of people don't think about
when they ship
is
what The most important thing you have
to think about is actually not finances.
It's actually not latency. It's can you
make it work?
You have to find the shortest path to
making it work as soon as possible. And
then you ship it. You ship an update.
You If you're really gated on number of
users cuz you're a large enterprise, you
gate how much users how whichever users
can use it behind a feature flag.
But you do not prevent You do not really
cuz you need to get real data from
production to actually know if it's
working. Your sample set is a
theoretical sample set. Kevin went one
step He got synthetic data. He went one
step further. Asked his Asked his
friends and family to actually give him
sample data. He actually got really
representative sample data from like a
real audience.
>> But the best he can do is get
>> Sorry, finish.
>> But the best thing he can do is actually
get real sample data from real users. So
It's
screw cost. Spend like
I don't know, spend like 5,000 bucks
collecting sample data if you're a large
entity. It It's worth it because the
representative data set is infinitely
more valuable for helping you iterate in
real time.
And like decide if it actually works. Go
do that, collect the data, and then once
it comes back
like then you can figure out how to go
update the model. And like if you think
about like from a cost perspective, like
engineering time and shipping speed is
the most valuable resource you have.
If shipping something If you're going to
ship one thing like 2 months later
because you wanted to collect data and
train a model or like update the prompts
ahead of time,
you just lost 2 months of shipping on a
product.
Like that's just not worth it, ever.
Just Just go ship the thing that works.
And then let's show the UI and stuff
while it's running.
>> Yeah, so So at first I didn't have a UI
at all, right? At first I dumped
everything into a JSON. Um and
>> the JSON by hand?
>> I was just reading the JSON by hand.
Um and obviously, you know, like you see
this and you're like what What do I do
with this?
>> How many of you have done this?
>> All the categories were here. This is
not Like this this wasn't useful. All
the information was here, but it just
plain wasn't useful.
And so,
you know, you I needed some sort of UI.
And so the question is, okay, so what's
a way that we can show this information
that's that shows what happens between
all these different breakpoints?
And my initial thought, I was looking at
the categories in the notebook. I mean,
they're they're obviously hierarchical,
right? Like we were saying before. So to
me, the most natural thing to do when
we're looking at something like this is
some sort of a tree-based diagram. Cuz
this is very naturally like this We
probably have five or six high-level
categories, and then they're you know,
they're the sub-branches. And so my
thought was using like a network X
um you know, visualization and uh
visualizing the tree as all these
different things are happening. And so
that's that's that's what I did. And if
we look over here, yeah, well, I can't
load Streamlit, so that'll that'll come
back, no problem. So, let me just zoom
in. And you can see this this is what I
initially did. And this is with just a
really small category, only I think
30-some categories, just to get it
working. And I only had like 14 things
come down from the embedders.
And um the LLM filtering was just like
one or two or three, I forget, but not
many. Um
And so this is, you know, this this
looks really good, right? This works
really well
in this case. You can see
um the things that got narrowed in the
first filter. And then, if you when you
would click to the next you know, the
LLM filter, you would see all the things
that got dropped out and what's still
left in the final answer.
>> What are you using to visualize these?
Is this just like a Python visualization
tool?
>> So, this yeah, this was NetworkX. And it
was using like I think yeah, Matplotlib
and NetworkX.
But I think there are a couple of of
problems with this, right? Like one is
for one like there are way too many
colors, right? The
the key has one, two, three, four, five,
six six categories. The green is very
obvious. The orange is pretty obvious.
But when you start getting into like
purple and blue, that's
it's not obvious immediately what all
the colors mean as you start getting
more complex, right? Here's another
example where it's just like what is
just looking at it, you have to look
back and forth between the the key,
which is not very helpful. It's not the
worst thing, but it's not immediately
obvious.
The bigger problem
is that this doesn't scale.
This is with
let me me 20 categories coming out of
the embedder, and then maybe I think
four or five coming out from the LLM,
right?
If you want to do the 100 categories and
25 categories, it it looks like this.
And this is
not at all useful.
Right? And so this is like what I
initially had. And I was like I first
was like, "Oh, this looks great." I
could even click between it. You can
literally see the orange ones become,
you know, little circles. Like, that's
cool. But, when you start getting into
even larger
you know, using all the categories and
with many more things packed into the
filters, it just doesn't scale. Like,
this is This is useless. This is almost
as bad as the JSON file.
And so
>> And it's somewhat worse cuz you can't do
command F.
>> Exactly. You can't do command F.
Exactly. You can't do command F. And you
can't like collapse the the the the the
sub-pieces of it.
So, you know, there's
So, and so Vivaldi helped me out with
this. He's like, you know, what what
would be more helpful with this? Um
And so, how do we
get all this information into a similar
amount of real estate?
And that's where the idea of the table
came from, right? You have a one column
for each filter, and you can sort it, so
you can just easily put all the ones
that they they made it to the one filter
at the top. And then you can color the
actual rows themselves. So, that's where
that ultimately came from.
>> Can you show that UI again just so
people can cross-compare? And I think
it's it's really
>> Um if this is done Okay, yeah. So, this
is done. So, let me I can Let me throw
up the UI.
>> Yeah, and I I want to Kevin gave me a
little bit too much credit that I helped
him out on that. I just told Kevin this
UI is [__] That's all I really said. It
doesn't look good. It doesn't feel Kevin
did something really natural, actually,
for anyone Sorry. Um what I said
politely was, "Kevin, this UI is could
use some work." Um
>> I think you said, "This isn't the right
view."
>> Yeah, I said, "This isn't the right
view." I was a little bit nicer.
Uh but, Kevin did something really
natural when he first approached this
problem that I think a lot of people do.
Which is they took the problem of like I
was like he had 1,400 categories, and he
said, "Let me just work with 20 of
them." That's actually a really really
really good approach. Cuz what Kevin
could do in that scenario is without
having to think about all this UI stuff,
he would actually just work on writing
code that worked. Like, that pipe on
that we drew out
it just took less effort for him to
iterate on that initial pipeline in the
beginning because that's how you iterate
in the very beginning.
>> Cuz we always talk about like the the
better your iteration loop is, the
faster you can change something and see
the result, the faster you will get to
the right solution. And we talk about
this is the same reason that like you
have like unit tests in Babel, right? Is
like how do you narrow the problem to
just one specific thing and then iterate
on that until it's good and then move on
to the next small thing.
>> Exactly. So
and I thought that was really clever.
And then once he did that, he built a UI
for that because like the JSON files
were useless effectively. Uh then once
we built the then once we built that,
what we ended up doing were actually
took that UI and said, "Now how does
this UI scale with all the categories?"
And the answer is it didn't. So then
Kevin just went back, thought about this
problem really hard, and then he came up
with this, which is
really good. I actually had no input on
this. This is all Kevin.
Um so he's giving like he's giving way
too much credit to us on the side, like
Show the downstream UI at the very
bottom. Uh the the table stuff. Not this
stuff. This was really cool personally.
>> This?
>> No, the other one where you can see the
individual test.
>> The individual test case.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I'll go to one that didn't work.
Yeah, this one.
>> You Exactly. And you can just see very
clearly what you what we ended up
picking and what we should have picked.
It's super visually clear.
>> Yeah, and this is one of the cases,
right? Where this is this is more
general. And so that's that that sparks
these conversations. I don't know if you
can zoom in more. But it picked
a lot more.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay, so it picked it picked mini split
air conditioner  mini split ACs,
and the correct one was technically just
mini split air.
>> All right, the correct one was this the
the red one cuz we missed it. So the
correct And you can see it really
clearly right up here, right? You can
see that the the ground truth was a
deeper category, but it picked a higher
up category, which again,
like
you don't think about
I might, you know, this might not
actually be an error until you look at
the table and you see, wait a second,
is, you know, if I were a user, would I
actually care if I got a, you know,
something more general where I would
probably just have these four categories
that I could click into versus if I got,
you know, something really specific and
I was trying to get into a sister
category or uh a parent category.
>> Yeah. Eugene Eugene sent something
really awesome. Eugene, we'd love to
chat with you. I'll find and then see if
we can bring you on for an episode, too,
for this kind of stuff, uh this kind of
deep dive. Uh but Benjamin said
something really fun, which was the
parent category and the sub cat uh sub
cat are the same thing. That is the
other thing you'll realize when you
actually start digging into the data in
detail.
Sometimes the data's just bad.
But even if you're being totally sane
and you build all these data sets,
sometimes the actual source of truth is
not a source of a truth as you think it
is.
>> So, wait, you're you're telling me that
when Claude code goes in and deletes the
test case because the can't get the test
to pass, that's sometimes the right
answer?
>> That's right. It might maybe it's always
the right answer. That's how you make
your code work. All the tests pass.
Um uh
Malik asked something really really good
and I want I actually wanted to I get
your take on this before we show the
results of the new thing, which is
how hard was this to build? So, let's
just put a time about I I'd love a time
estimate from you, Kevin, like from
from phase one of actually getting the
code to work, pure code working, not the
UIs or anything. How long did the code
take to write? Like the test harness and
everything else?
>> So, once I had the code working,
>> Let's Yeah, let's How long did it take
to get the code working? Like that's
just the core pipeline, the BAML
function and then dynamic typing.
>> Yeah.
Um
couple hours.
>> Okay. And then how long did it take to
get the test harness?
>> What do you mean the test harness?
>> Like the one where you actually pass in
test cases, you dump out JSON files, you
do all that stuff.
>> Oh, yeah, that's that's what I meant.
Yeah, a couple hours. And then the whole
thing was like So, the actual
cuz yeah, I mean, I kind of did it I did
it together.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so a couple of hours
>> most of it.
>> Hard coded most of it. Yeah.
>> No, cloud coded most of it.
>> Oh, cloud coded a lot of it. Yeah, yeah,
cloud coded most of it.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then once you did that, how long
did the first version of the UI take you
to build?
The one with the little nodes and
everything else.
>> Mhm.
Um probably
probably four to five hours, maybe.
>> Okay, four to five hours? And then how
many hours
>> was a little stream was a little iffy.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, no, it's fine. I think it's good
to
good to give people an estimate of how
long they should be spending on these
tasks before they should go think about
them. And what about the final task?
Like this final UI, how long did this
take? Like you just changed the prompt,
you ran the whole thing, it was really
freaking fast. How long did this take
you to run?
>> So,
probably was
There was we There was a lot of back and
forth cuz I I it took me a while to
figure out the right UI, but that whole
process probably took me
um
probably closer to like
s-
five to eight hours
to really nail down the UI. Because it's
I think part of the part of the
challenge is like And I think this is
what the the point we're trying to get
across is like you don't always know the
right thing to build to visualize it
until you build the wrong thing and it's
like it's not very useful, it's not very
helpful. Right? So, there was a lot of
kind of
things between that and this
that um
uh
that I had to like iterate through in
order to get here. But I'd say once I
had that kind of tree diagram, like
this one, getting to here took probably
yeah, another five to eight hours.
>> So, it sounds like what I'm hearing is
this took about roughly two full days of
work
to get from like never having heard the
problem to To heard the problem, written
the code to having a test harness built
that you feel like you would feel
comfortable showing like your team and
having them iterate on it.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool. Um so, that's like the approximate
timeline that people should think about
is like it's not like Cloud Code and all
these other things are great at writing
code. I'm guessing like all of this is
pretty much AI code gen the whole time.
>> A lot of it. A lot of it.
>> Right? And the beautiful part is because
most of this UI stuff is throwaway code,
you can kind of view it like Jupiter
notebooks where like you don't actually
have to save them forever.
And just like get rid of them uh along
the way uh once you're done with it and
you ship the project. And just make sure
the core part of your code, your actual
pipeline that you're running,
that is good code. Your test harness
code doesn't have to be good code
because that can be thrown away
long-term. It's not actually going to
customers. It just needs to be able to
be run really quickly, and you need to
be able to adapt it with Cloud Code, so
it shouldn't be like that messy.
But, it's um I would say like the most
important thing is just like make sure
your core code is good and like
Vibe code the rest of it. Vibe code the
UIs, Vibe code the Evals, Vibe code the
testing harness.
But, do Vibe code them. Don't skip those
parts. Don't only build the main app
part of the application.
>> Yeah. One of the the things that Vibe
Ops said to me was that um
like kind of if you can think of it, you
can build it now. Like it's basically
free to build these things.
So,
yeah, the real the real art and
engineering comes into figuring out
like
what gives me the most what gives me the
information I care about in the densest
way that makes it jump right off the
page.
>> Yeah. I'm going to show another question
actually that came up while we were
discussing
uh which was
uh should we Vibe code this in React?
Why do we use Streamlit?
Um and this is the mistake a lot of
people make. This UI is not important.
Kevin, I asked him a very direct I was
originally going to suggest React. I
asked Kevin a question of like
uh Kevin, how well do you know He was
like, I know Python. I was like, don't
think about it. Just use Streamlit. Like
it's just like don't ask questions.
Don't try and be optimal in parts of the
system that don't need to be optimized.
Who cares if his UI is perfect? It just
needs to work. Does, what are your
thoughts on this process? I know you've
you're pretty much what I would call the
vibe coding expert. I take a lot of
advice from you on this. Like, how would
you approach this kind of stuff?
>> A great question. Yeah, so I mean a lot
of people talk to me and like we're even
learning this internally on like how to
vibe code things that are a lot like
have a tighter iterate iteration loop.
And so we're still tuning like the the
process that I'm sure everyone here has
heard about plenty at this point is this
like research plan implement. Um
it actually doesn't work we're like
figuring out alternative flows where we
do like plan and then implement and then
go back and do the research for things
that are more visual, for things that
are harder for an AI to validate by
writing deterministic tests. Like even
with Playwright, it's just kind of hard
to vibe out a UI without looking at it.
And so like one of the things we've done
been doing a lot lately is like I will
go and like not do any planning up
front. Maybe do a research that is just
like show me the files that matters. But
then I'll dump jump straight into back
and forth vibe coding and get the thing
we're like doing a style change, right?
I want to get the thing looking how I
want. And the CSS that gets generated is
usually trash. It's like got like
important like exclamation points all
over the place. It's like not how CSS
should be written. But I get it looking
how I want and then I take pictures of
that and then I share that with the team
and then one of our expert front end
engineers will go back and actually do
research plan implement to turn it into
like build a production grade
implementation of it. So, that's kind of
a little bit of a detour, but the idea
is like for things where it's like the
value is the humans like ability to
understand what's happening. I think you
should end up doing a lot more like
tight loop iteration with the LLM to
learn what you want and then if it's a
side project like this maybe you keep
what you got if it's
something that needs to go into
production and be production grade code
then then maybe you go back and build it
from from scratch.
This is if you if you've read there's a
book called inspired by a guy named
Marty Cagan which is kind of like 20
years ago developed a lot of the like
principles of good product management
and the idea of product management that
um
isn't a lot of people's heads is kind of
like a Jira ticket pusher or like the
decider of what gets built and Marty's
take is basically like your job as a
product manager as someone building a
thing and deciding what should be built
is to learn as quickly as possible. And
so if you can get customer feedback
based on a bunch of Figma mockups and
people will say like yeah I would pay
$100,000 for that that's way better than
spending 3 months building it and then
showing it to people and finding out
nobody wants it. And so like that's kind
of zooming out on like tactical advice
like that's kind of the core principle
is like how can you give yourself the
most leverage to be able to understand
what you want. And if you're building
for yourself then yeah just prototype it
vibe code it whatever it is. I think I
use vibe I'm not good at Figma so I use
I use vibe coding as a substitute for
Figma and I think a lot of people I
think there was like a Lenny's podcast
like 9 months ago where they talk about
Amjad from Replit was like and I haven't
talked to Amjad for I haven't talked to
Amjad ever
but 9 months ago at least what he said
was like people are using Replit agent
as product managers to prototype what
they want and show it to customers and
understand what people want and then if
they decide they want it then that
becomes the specification that goes to
the engineers and they talk about okay
how do we build this in a way that's
scalable and production grade and secure
and all that stuff.
>> almost think of this UI as something if
you're building a Jupyter notebook this
is what you would have shown.
Now you can show something better than
Jupyter notebook.
Like this UI does that and I think that
is like the mentality that I found is
like
to go this house.
>> And models are much better at writing
Streamlit apps than they are writing
Jupiter notebooks. I will tell you that.
They're They're getting there and like
people have done incredible I've written
Jupiter notebooks to do Bambu workshops
using Claude code, but it doesn't work
as well and like you really as most
people say like you need to be able to
design a testing harness. And so like
the hard part of using a coding agent to
write something like a Jupiter notebook
is like, okay, how do I build a separate
script that actually runs the notebook
headless with no output and runs every
single cell and make sure there's no
errors so that the AI as it's making
changes has a feedback loop to like
there's no linter for Jupiter notebooks.
The best way to linter Jupiter notebook
is actually run it.
>> Do you want to show the results, Kevin?
Um from the most recent result. Let's
see what happened. I don't I I have no
idea.
>> Yeah.
Let's go to error.
Oh, look at that. So before
>> Did it get worse?
>> No, it got better. So we are at Oops.
See, and we were at version
Yeah.
So we were here since
Oh, it didn't change actually.
>> The distribution it didn't really
change. So it's not it's like in this
scenario using a better Can you change
the definition?
>> So lenient Oh, we got Okay, so we got up
to 84% which is
>> And what about if we go to the other
lenient?
>> I think it's the same.
>> No, no, the other lenient. There's
another lenient.
>> The other lenient. Yeah, where it looks
at like more specific as opposed to
strict.
Okay, got up to 85%.
>> Yeah. And then the other one is
>> Yeah, what is V1?
Yeah.
>> Much similar.
Around the same.
>> Did you run V1 with GPT-4o? Is that what
happened?
>> No.
Well, I think what it means is like in
this problem in this problem the problem
is not
the problem is clearly not the model.
It's like the definition likely of the
categories is what needs to be updated
to make it work better.
That's almost definitely what I would
have to do here. It's actually not about
the prompt. I would just go and look at
the actual prompt for each category and
be like, "Okay, for these cat And like
if we go look at them, can we go look at
some of the error cases in V5?"
>> I'll just pick some failures, yeah.
>> And just go dig into this. And I think
people can get a grasp of how like we're
thinking about these problems. Like
let's pick this. So the user said
um
desk shelves.
Honestly,
I'd probably be like this passes. Like
it's sub-optimal, but I'm like
it
it it it looks pretty good.
>> Yeah.
>> And maybe they didn't want decorating
shelving, but they probably want
shelving.
Um
>> Mhm.
>> And that's probably what I would pick it
as. I think the ground truth is wrong.
Let's look at the next one.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's just go through and like look at
some There's only 10 cases.
Cool. That one passes. We're good.
>> Mhm. Oh, this is This Yeah, this was a
one of the really interesting ones.
>> Or gasket seal?
Actually, it's correct. The ground truth
is wrong, right?
I guess these are parts.
>> Yeah.
>> Um which one is it? I actually don't
know.
Um let's go on to the next one cuz it's
like it's very close on that one.
>> Induction stove.
Oh, interesting. Induction ranges like
that's fine.
Right?
>> So I think I think what I really took
away from this like we've looked at a
bunch of these errors. It honestly looks
like there's just like two categories
for each of these as multiple categories
that are actually correct answers.
So what I would actually probably do is
I'd probably go back to my ground truth
to some and make it an array.
Like actually before updating the prompt
and say like, "Any of these ground
truths are fine."
Uh as long as I pick one of them. And I
likely will in my UI
make it a another thing where in my UI
I'd actually say, "Here's the selection
I made, but you might have also meant
this."
And show them a totally separate
category that's related. So I'd both
make a UI change and an eval change over
here.
So, exactly like Andrew said, what we do
is if you go back to your code, um
I would literally just take this and the
pick best category would just become a
category array.
I'd say pick the top three categories
here that make sense.
Or like and then I'd be like and just
have the user go select that and then
I'm done. And I in my UI I'd pick one as
the primary.
And for the secondary, I would go ahead
and just pop it into my UI somewhere in
the final application that says, here's
the breadcrumb layout, but you might
have also meant this one instead.
Because it's like sampling through these
is like I let's go on. Let's see if we
see any that are actually wrong.
>> Interesting. Okay.
>> Like that's okay. It's it's two parts
for wine coolers.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And then appliance parts and beverage
coolers. You're like the fluorescent
bulbs, S shelves.
>> And I think this is kind of what I meant
by sometimes the data is wrong.
If you just took this as a raw metric
and you didn't dig in, you'd be like,
oh, this system's only 80% correct. But
if we actually looked at 100% of the
failure cases, all of them are actually
not failures. It's a problem
specification problem much more so than
a failure.
Like my data is just polluted
with bad data.
Where
>> It's it's
it was created by people who don't
really know much about hardware stores.
>> Yeah, or like the
>> It might only have like the categories
have so much overlap.
>> Exactly. And like it's going to be wrong
in that scenario. There's nothing that
they can do about this.
Um but
um
this was really really fun, Kevin. Thank
you for going into this really deep with
us. Um this code will be checked into
the repo. We'll send a summary of the
video out. I know we missed last week's
summary. You guys will get a summary, I
promise.
Um for last week. We've just had a very
very um
uh busy week and we'll announce shortly
why.
But um
questions for anyone. Feel free to pop
them into the chat um and or raise your
hand or something and we can bring you
on.
>> Yeah, this is cool. I'm going to share
real quick. Um,
Nick shared an old article. Um,
Let's see. Let's get a tab.
>> Uh, Kevin, you want to stop screen
sharing? There we go.
>> Yeah, there I got it. So, this is this
people have been trying to figure out
research opportunities in e-commerce
search for a very long time. This is an
older paper from 2020.
Um, but it's just a single You can go
find a hundred other papers on this
topic. And so, there's This is uh, as
far as I'm concerned, these are like not
toy problems. This is a real thing that
a lot of people are trying to figure
out.
>> These problems are worth millions and
millions of dollars. Um, like hundreds
of millions of dollars.
Um,
>> And yes, Andrew, we can apply this to
categorizing architecture for how you do
tool calling. We actually did an episode
about this of like, if you have a
thousand MCP tools and like, this is
coming back to the coding agents thing.
I think Jeff Huntley did a talk recently
where he I mean, lots of people have
highlighted this. If you add the GitHub
MCP server to your Claude code and you
don't turn off any of the tools, it's
60,000 tokens of just tool definitions.
And that's going to tank your
performance compared to like And a tool
call is the same as a classification in
in many points. We're asking the model
to output structured data about what
type of thing is this, whether it's
like, what type of thing is this query
about or what is the right next step in
the workflow based on what the user is
asking for. So, the same concepts there
of like, how do you narrow And there's
actually there's a post on the very top
of Hacker News right now of a team who
built an MCP server to allow you to kind
of like inject a thousand tools or
thousands of tools into your AI and that
does the narrowing on the MCP side for
you because that's the only way to do
it.
>> doing the same thing Kevin did here. We
they just use some embedding or some LLM
filter to like go from a thousand to 50
to a hundred. This code is really easy
to go write.
Um, if you guys like this kind of
content, this is AI that works. If you
want to tune in next time, we're going
to do another fun episode. You can check
out the link here, and we'll get back to
answering questions in a bit. But like
this is like one of my favorite things
to do every week. Um, it's very fun
compared to the regular
work that we get to do every day.
Um, and it's just a nice break for us.
Um, Mike asked a really good question
of, "What do you think of ML flow? Is it
dead uh since by putting UI is so easy?"
Personally, I think I mean, I've totally
stake the horse in this. I think we need
a new programming language to go solve
some of these iteration loop problems.
Um, like there's just a totally
different workflow that people have now
that has never been true before. You
need to iterate and code at the same
time.
And like you wouldn't use some you
wouldn't use like uh you wouldn't use a
bunch of HTML code to do what React can
do.
And you probably shouldn't use a bunch
of random smashed together ginger uh not
ginger uh
Jupiter notebooks to like build a prod
production app. And like I think like
things like ML flow long term are not
just not going to be as good. Um, what
do you do eval? How do you eval? How do
you do evals on candidate screening
chat?
Something that is conversational not
zero or one range based evals. Um, so
like how do you do dynamic evals?
We did an episode on evals a while ago
um episode five that talks about some of
this stuff, but I think we should go
deeper into this. But Dex, Kevin, how
would you guys think about this? Like
let's say we have a chatbot and we want
to build an eval system for it. What
would be your first gut?
>> If I wasn't going to vibe code the UI,
>> Well, you you might vibe code the UI,
but how would you define the problem
with eval? How do you define success,
ground truth, or something along that
array?
>> I mean, I'm just going to say what we
said in the we did that episode a while
ago that was like policy to prompts, and
it was like how do you take, you know, a
terabyte of not not terabyte. It was
like several gigs of like raw email
content, and how do you like evaluate
that against certain compliance rules to
decide if the emails were breaking
certain rules of like what is ethical
corporate behavior or whatever it is and
it's like start as small as possible
pick a really narrow thing and pick a
really narrow slice of the data and
don't grow the problem or the slice. You
have two dimensions you can play with,
right? And I think you kind of want to
grow them in parallel. Like okay, now
we're going to do two problems and run
it across the 100 emails and then you're
like okay, those are working. Now let's
do 1,000 emails and let's try and you
just keep iterating as small as possible
so that like you want to start in a way
cuz the first like going from 40%
accuracy to 80 or 90% accuracy, you can
probably get most of that from a really
small data set and you want to be able
to go look at the data. If you start by
dumping in 10,000 emails, one, your
iteration loop is going to be way slower
and two, you are going to not want to go
look at the data. So frame your problem
in a way where you can vibe eval it
either by creating a UI on top of it or
just by looking what do what Kevin did
was like start by looking at the JSON
and then when you have so many cases
that you can't read the JSON anymore,
then make it easier to read and easier
to debug and easier to work. Why not
just iterate and code using cursor
instead of baml?
>> Um uh before we go to that one. Uh
Kevin, what are your thoughts? How would
you approach the chat problem? Like if
there's a chatbot you want to build an
eval for?
>> Yeah, I mean that's a that's a really
tough one for me. Um I think
I really like everything that Deck said.
I think
um the first thing that I would do is is
is think about it on a kind of a a
problem by problem basis. It's like what
is the cuz it's
that's a really big problem. It's just
cuz like what is
is is this chat good? Is this is this
what we wanted this to look like, right?
That's that's almost an impossible
question to answer and so I would try to
break it down into like really
individual questions. It's like kind of
like to Deck's point, right? Like is
this chat following this rule?
And then I would you know build test
cases and kind of vibe code and build my
UI and then I would keep, you know, just
keep adding more roles.
And then
uh you know, adding more chats and kind
of try like Dex was saying, kind of
trying to doing the horizontal and
vertical. Um and see where that got me.
>> One thing I think that I have found
successful in these kinds of domains for
like really, really ambiguous problems
is like instead of thinking about like
hey, I just screw the AI part, and then
let's just think about a um let's just
think about a world where we're doing a
call we're running a call center. How do
call centers run? You have people taking
the calls.
You have people that randomly spot check
their calls. And then you kind of go up
the chain and it just goes up the chain
forever, basically, until you basically
get this. But what they really do to
make all of this work is actually tie
all of this
to actually um
deal with um
to deal with um
end of end of line business metrics.
It's like how much how many returns are
we getting? How many orders are we
getting through? How many sales calls
are we getting through? It's really easy
to tie it to revenue at that point. And
so what you can do is you just
you're just like hey, we have a median
revenue number that we're running across
the whole company.
This group is performing worse. This
group is performing better. And what you
do is you just spot check and you just
say is there can I see something that
makes this spot check worse? So before
you actually build evals,
just spot check. Spot check, spot check,
spot check. And but tie it to an end
business metric.
Like putting a chatbot on a page is
freaking useless unless you can tie it
to an end business metric of some kind
because you won't actually be able to
converge on anything meaningful.
And then once you can do that, you can
spot check, make a change, and see if
the metric goes up. And you can do it
localize. You can say I will do this
metric for this kind of user persona. I
have a chatbot on the website, and if a
Python user comes up, I expect their
Python code to be I expect the code
sample that spins up by default to be
Python. If a Rust user comes up, I
expect their code that generates to be
Rust.
That's an easy thing to go build a
system for my chatbot to make it work,
and I can build like memory or whatever
I need to go solve this problem.
But, the end business metric I might be
is the number of times people copy and
paste code directly from the site. If
they copy and paste code directly from
the site,
that gives me a key metric on how good
it's how good it is.
If they copy and paste code on the first
generation of the site, on the first
generation of code versus the fifth
generation code, that tells me how long
it takes to get to good code snippets.
So, it's almost like I can I can
I can build a pseudo metric of something
and even for most problems.
But, I think you just have to go and
think about how do you tie this to the
end result that you're trying to drive
in some way and then like you can build
any sort of UI UX you you want around
that, but you should build UI UX and you
should look at chat logs and spot check.
I think there's one last question is
like why not iterate using cursor to
code code deterministic code instead of
vibe code the entire solution and use
like probabilistic models
uh from Wagdin. And I think this
question is really interesting. I think
uh Eugene in the chat was saying great
point. I was like, "Hey, we use
deterministic code to solve some of this
classification problem." I suspect maybe
a decision tree or something of that
kind or something else along that road.
And that's not a bad solution, but
there's certain problems that are just
hard. Like, for example,
in the past world when we used to go and
say if there was an object in an image,
we used to do a lot of computer vision
math to go figure that out. Now, I
literally just toss this at an LM and
say, "What is this?" and it'll tell me
what this is.
It is really nice that I can just go do
that and don't have to train a model to
like train it on like charger blocks.
But, the trade-off is it may get this
wrong. So, I'm living in this world
where I'm getting much more capable
systems at the cost of accuracy.
And it's kind of like when I use Python
for the very very first time in my
uh
in my life and I trade off performance
to get really fast ways to ship code.
Like, I could have written C++ code and
managed memory myself or I can write
Python and just ship it.
And the trade-off there that you should
think about is like people used to be
like, "Oh, why not just manage the
memory yourself?" Well, it turns out as
computers got better,
we didn't need to. It was okay to use
for like this app remember size probably
using a 70 gigs of RAM or something
stupid on this on this machine while
we're running this, and that's okay.
None of us care. The internet systems
are good enough. Uh the computers are
good enough. That's not the problem of
today.
So, I think it's the same with LLMs.
Where like you should use them sometimes
uh because they're really good
calculators.
And they're they're a little
probabilistic, but
sometimes that's okay for the kinds of
problems that they have. And like Eugene
said, it's just like
they're just problems that are better
for LLMs.
Um and there are problems that are bad
for LLMs, and you got to understand
them.
But, there are problems that are good
for them, and you should use them.
Um I think that's it for questions
today. Um but again, always a pleasure
having everyone on here. Thank you guys
for joining us on this Tuesday morning
as per usual.
Um if you guys want to come check it out
in the future,
sign up here, and we'll put on a new
episode pretty shortly, and likely we'll
do dynamic UIs coming in soon
um for this one and show this off. But,
Kevin,
huge huge props from from me and I'm
certain Kevin
>> Dude, this was a blast. Thank you so
much for sharing this and for hustling
on this. And like I know I know we do a
lot of coding prep for these episodes
most of the time.
I have I have called myself out when we
underprepared, but I know how much work
goes into stuff like this. And I know
you've been having fun hacking, but I
don't want to like diminish that like
you put in a ton of work to like hack on
this and find something that works. So,
I hope you learned a lot, and it was
super fun having you on, and I would
encourage everybody else to get hands-on
and try some of this stuff and get in
touch and and tell us how it went.
>> Yeah.
Well, thanks for having me. This was a
blast.
>> All right, everyone. Um thank you guys
soon. We're going to log off and get
back to work.
>> Catch y'all.
See you.